لقد شعرت في الواقع بالذنب الشديد لأنني خاضت
الكثير من الصراع لسنوات عديدة عندما
بدأت الرياضة لأول مرة شعرت أنها
ربما كانت تتعارض مع ديني وقد
اعتدت حقًا على تمزيقي
في نفس الوقت الذي أحببت فيه الرياضة وأنا
لم أستطع أن أفهم كيف يمكن أن يكون هذا
خطأ ، أدركت أنني كنت أعيش
حياة مزدوجة ، فأنا تعرف أن واحدة كانت
فتاة تقليدية لطيفة في المنزل والأخرى
حيث كنت أذهب إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية وكان هذا
جانبًا آخر مني
أتذكر  في المرة الأولى التي دخلت فيها إلى
صالة الألعاب الرياضية ، كنت في الثامنة عشرة من عمري ، كانت
بيئة يهيمن عليها الذكور تمامًا ، لكن
لم يواجهني أي من ذلك ، وكل ما أردت فعله
هو المشاركة في الرياضة التي
صممها التايلانديون كفن حربي.  اعتادوا
استخدامه للدفاع عن بلدهم ،
يُعرف باسم فن الأطراف الثمانية ، إنه
بأقصى سرعة وبسرعة كاملة ، وهي
واحدة من أصعب الرياضات في العالم ،
لذا قد يكون الأمر مخيفًا للغاية ، لقد
بدأت بالفعل تدريبي الرياضي مع بيل الذي لديه
بالفعل  أصبح مثل لي
بالنسبة لي ، لقد أخذني تحت جناحه
في نفس الوقت الذي يرتدي فيه
قبعة مدربه ، فهذا يعني أنه عمل لا يمكنني الخروج
بأعذار لا أستطيع أن أنينها من
الألم أو أنني أمضي يومًا سيئًا  عندما تكون
في وضع التدريب ، فأنت تتدرب على
حقيقة أنني أنتمي إلى
خلفية إسلامية تقليدية ، من غير المعتاد تمامًا
ممارسة رياضة مثل المورتاي ، كنت
أخشى أن تخبرني عائلتي
بالرياضة أو أتذكر عودتهم إلى المنزل
يومًا ما  ونظر والدي إلي ،
فقال لي لماذا نبدو مثل الملاكم في
تلك المرحلة ، كنت خائفًا جدًا من
أن الانقسام سيُسلب مني ،
وركضت إلى غرفتي ، وحصلت على كأس واحد
أخفيته لأنني اعتقدت أن هذا
ربما يكون المفتاح الوحيد الذي تركه بعيدًا هو
ترك الصندوق الذي قررت أن أخبرهم
به واشتريت والدي إلى صالة الألعاب
الرياضية لطمأنته أن كل ما كنت أفعله هو
ممارسة بعض الانضباط في حياتي
بدلاً من الخروج في الشارع
للحصول على  متورطًا في أشياء
لا يجب أن أعلم أنها تعرفها فقط
ما أفعله في وقت فراغي
يكفي لي
لمواصلة وجعلهم فخورين ، لا
أريد أن أمشي بعيدًا جالسًا في
غرفة تغيير الملابس أبكي من عيني
معتقدًا أنه كان بإمكاني القيام بعمل أفضل ، في
الواقع لقد كان ذلك بداخلي  للفوز في تلك
المعركة لكني استسلمت
[تصفيق
] أنا فقط ضد ، انسى أمر
مدربيها ، نسيان مؤيديها ،
كل شيء يتعلق بما يمكنني فعله في هذه
الدقائق العشر من حياتي
[تصفيق]
ليس لديك وقت للأعصاب حقًا
كل ما تفكر فيه هو
ضرب رقبتك استراتيجيتك ، هل هي تعمل ، أليس الأمر
أنني أؤذي خصمي ، هل أنا
فزت بالقتال أو ما الذي أحتاج إلى
تغييره ، لذا فمن الواضح أنك تكتيكي للغاية
[تصفيق]
إذا علقت مع
لقطة شريرة تحاول مواجهتها
بسرعة كبيرة والعودة إلى
خطة لعبتك
[تصفيق]
لكسب حريق هو أحد أكثر
المشاعر المدهشة في العالم ، إنه
يؤكد لك أن كل هذا صعب  عمل كل هذا
التضحية بكل شيء من
حولك ذ  أنت الفريق من حولك ،
أخصائي التغذية ، شركائك في التدريب كل
تلك الليالي التي تدرب فيها المتدرب على العودة إلى المنزل
مع كدمات ، كل ما هو جدير بالاهتمام
الموهبة ليس كافيًا ، كل شيء
يتعلق بالتضحية ، كل شيء يتعلق
بالتفرغ ولن تنتهي أبدًا
حتى تستسلم